[Music]
in time you will know what it's like to
lose read it run from it the end is near
we got one advantage
we have a dance once
so that's what we use
I think it's good except it sucks so let
me do the plan and that way it might be
really good
Wow today we don't flash for one minute
we fight for one of them
put that thing away now I don't want to
tell you again
[Music]
right it
running from it is near we're gonna need
some help
Patti bitbucket not bad for the end of
the world
Jared don't fight for while
we fight for all of them
Avengers infinity war when you said we
were going to open what conduct to the
rest of the world this is not what I
imagined or give you imagine the
Olympics maybe even if Starbucks
everywhere April 27 he won't stop until
he destroys half the universe everything
you known everything you love it will
all be gone
[Applause]
together
we can stop flannels
[Music]
you don't want to trade
but we were
[Music]
the entire time and with Thanos he only
ever had one call
to worry about half the universe we are
out of time
[Music]
the end is near
[Music]
get tickets now the entire time I knew
him he only ever had one call
to wipe out half the universe if he gets
all the Infinity stones she can do it
with the snap of his fingers just like
that tell me he's name again Danis
[Music]
we got one advantage
he's coming to us
we have a dance once so that's what we
use
[Music]
let's talk about this plan tears I think
it's good except it sucks so let me do
the plan and that way it might be really
good
Wow
in is near
une undone
[Music]
half of humanity will still exist
perfectly balanced
as all things should be
I hope they remember you
[Music]
I'm Peter by the way dr. strange oh
you're using your made-up names then I
am spider-man so this is it it's always
leading illness
ready let's go
[Music]
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more so when they
needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
[Music]
[Music]
in time you will know what it's like to
lose feel so desperately that you're
right
yet to fail all the same
read it
run from it destiny still alive
[Music]
evacuate the city
engage your defenses
and get this man a sheet
[Music]
fun isn't something one considers
imbalancing the universe
but this does put a smile on my face
[Music]
[Music]
how are you guys before creation itself
there were six singularities forged into
Infinity stones
this is our first day here we are
Pinewood in Atlanta and it's it's
actually pretty unbelievable day one of
what promises to be a year of fun-filled
lensing I remember actually going to see
the first Avengers with one of my best
mates from home and I'd never have
dreamed that I'd ever be in one of these
movies let alone playing spider-man I
feel like I'm on top of the world
because this is just mind-blowing
what we always try to do at marvel
studios is we're building the cinematic
universe is look at the big picture how
can things relate across movies and
across years Avengers infinity war is
the culmination of the entire Marvel
Cinematic Universe as started in May of
2008 with a release of Iron Man 1 and it
really is an unprecedented culmination
of a series of films interlinked
together which at the time had never
been done before and for us the
important thing is making it all come
together we know they're gonna face
Thanos we've been setting that up since
Avengers 1 how do you do that in a way
that is unexpected that pits the
Avengers against somebody who's more
powerful than anyone they faced and yet
make them completely unprepared to face
him well tear them apart which is why we
did Civil War before infinity war as we
were conceiving and executing civil war
the end of that movie was very much a
setup for what these movies would be we
always have a sense of that
tony is not talking to Steve the
Avengers are basically a name with
nobody in it the world is vulnerable
Tony
senses his greater threat approaching
and so he is doing everything in his
power to keep deer safe
[Music]
fan OHS shows us why he's the biggest
the best the baddest villain that we've
ever had and the most frightening
villain that the Avengers have ever
faced the most exciting part is the
incredible roster of well developed
characters and it's going to create a
really combustible exciting massive
scale adventure you know that we're onto
something within the studio when we hit
upon an idea or we see a piece of
concept art and all of us in the room go
this is cool and an Avengers infinity
war the avengers will meet the guardians
of the galaxy
because of what Marvel is because of
what they have done over the last ten
years
these next two Avengers films will be an
event like no one has ever seen on film
before
[Music]
[Music]